you're being very loud computer that's
okay you sound like the ocean said a kid
that's only ever lived in Nebraska so I
was talking to my friend Diane Kang the
other day I say her first and last name
as if I think you might not think that
she's a human being but she's a human
being I have friends that are humans I
know I'm shocked - lipstick is like
cleavage for the face draws the eye in
that's no focus on my value is here I
was talking to my friend Diane the other
day she mentioned that she thought that
there was a lack of videos on YouTube
specifically dedicated to teaching new
adults how to be adults in the mundane
activities that everyone assumes we all
know how to do but the reality is no one
actually teaches us the easy things like
cleaning a bathroom taking out your
garbage dishes taxes nope I'm not going
to get into that pumping gas etc etc etc
etc etc and so forth and I thought yeah
I wasn't actually taught how to do a lot
of adult things and if I was it
definitely wasn't paying attention and
so I still maintain to this day I wasn't
actually taught so I thought it would be
fun to create a series once a month
called how to adult laptop for short and
aggressive and every month I'll make a
video teaching you how I best know how
to do some adult thing and I want on my
Facebook page facebook.com slash grace
Helbig and ask you guys what are some
things that you wish someone taught you
outright how to do as an adult and this
month I thought let's go and laundry
because I have to do my laundry and I
have to make a video for you I want to
make a video for
next month I'll teach you how to pretend
to feel things but first let's learn how
to do laundry here we go we're gonna
learn how to do our laundry the first
thing you're gonna do is look at the
mess you've made this has come from you
life is a series of creation and
destruction
these clothes are once clean now they're
dirty you're going to clean them again
but for what we're all going to die
someday
so is it actually worth it then we're
going to take a quick look at our
clothes and hate them so much and then
look at the dirty clothes and just feel
pain then we're going to take a cute
moment to contemplate our own mortality
under the cute clock we got from Ikea
then we're going to pack all of our
laundry into the hamper we got from
Target wicker berry bohemian New England
chic then we're going to have a super
cute moment of rage against an inanimate
object and then we're in take our
laundry to the washer dryer and how
would you look at that washers in the
same place as our feelings inside a
cabinet tucked away cute so essentially
to do your laundry you're going to take
your dirty clothes and put them in your
washer and now feel free to pause this
video go back rewatch take it in learn
moving forward a lot of experts and
television commercials say that you
should separate your dogs from your
lights so that they don't mix colors in
the wash and ruin each other however
based on the internet a lot of things
like those statements can be taken out
of context I'm just going to like throw
everything in together without a care in
the world other than deep consideration
for not offending someone that doesn't
understand what I'm saying in the first
place yay internet and oops look at that
we found clothes with the price tags
still left on them fun so just use your
teeth next we're going to put the
laundry detergent into the washer the
detergent is liquid stuff that takes
away all of the mistakes some call it
the vodka of laundry and just like human
bodies washing machines have so many
holes so I forgo all of those holes and
usually take a tide packet not sponsored
cut damnit internet but tide packets are
wrapped up
sacks that conveniently have everything
you need to take all the sins away from
your clothing so just like sex take that
wrapped up sack and toss it in the big
hole and hope it turns out okay and then
we get to the button situation now this
is different for every washing machine
and I don't know how to do it so I treat
it like slot machine I have fun I push a
button and I let it ride then you walk
away mission accomplished but you don't
want to walk away like a German soldier
so you're not going to polarize and then
if you're lucky you'll experience one of
the greatest moments in an adult's life
and that is remembering that you started
to do your laundry in the first place
and are able to move your damp clothes
to the dryer which is the next step and
then you put dryer sheets in but for
some reason my camera didn't capture
that moment but trust me I did it I'm
always three sheets and then you get
back to the praying part and you can
pray in a lot of ways according to the
Internet there's no one way also make
sure you check your lint trap that is
the most dangerous trap of all and also
you can turn your lint into the old man
emoji and make yourself have a great
night because you're fun and you don't
need anyone other than the land then at
some point you wake up in the middle of
the night remember that you started your
laundry and hate yourself for forgetting
it and hate all of your family members
for not ever teaching you how to do it
and then you just start folding it this
is how you fold laundry you just fold it
and then you find somehow there were
headphones in your wash that's a sign of
good luck you continue on and you keep
folding until your laundry is done and
you walk away like a champion a warrior
like a real capable adult well there you
go there are my best attempts at
teaching you how to do laundry
haha laundry I hope this up leave a
comment down below on what you want to
haha about next month I don't know
when you put lipstick on your mouth
everything is pronounced